buenos días para ustedes raixi a pesar
de que falta el 10% del escrutinio de
estos votos ya se puede dar como
presidente de la república ya tanto el
presidente de hasan rohan y como el
resto de los candidatos han reconocido a
su victoria así que lo que nos va a
esperar con un presidente radical como
usted decía es en el enfoque económico
es un enfoque más social la economía ha
marcado estas elecciones como
consecuencia de la gran crisis que
atraviesa el país hay varios factores
las sanciones económicas impuestas por
el gobierno de donald trump en el 2018
la pandemia y también el mal manejo
económico de algunos algunos momentos de
las políticas del presidente hassan
rohan y todo esto influido para que la
clase media cada vez se sienta más
empobrecida la inflación supere el 50
por ciento
ibrahim raeissi ha hablado de a dar
mucho más apoyo a la población a través
de subsidios casas especialmente para
los jóvenes y así se puedan casar porque
los grandes problemas que tiene irán es
el desempleo en la juventud y aquellos
que tienen trabajo pues tienen unos
salarios mínimo
y para está para este sistema
conservador el más religioso es muy
importante conservar esa base social y
que las personas sigan casándose y
teniendo hijos que también es una
prioridad para este sistema que se ve
cada vez más envejecido la población
ahora ni cada vez es más vieja catalina
en términos de política internacional
cuáles serían las posiciones de raíz y
en cuanto a temas como las relaciones
con eeuu e irak o la revitalización del
acuerdo nuclear de 2015 bueno hemos
estamos en este momento revolución
debemos negociando perdón este acuerdo
nuclear para que vuelva a reactivarse en
viena esto va a seguir porque esto es
una política de estado que viene del
consejo de seguridad nacional así que lo
que va a cambiar es la manera de hacerlo
ese lenguaje esa manera de aproximarse
que es que va a ser mucho más difícil
mucho más radical de la que hemos visto
con el gobierno de hasan rohan y así que
los diplomáticos extranjeros
especialmente los norteamericanos y
europeos tendrán más dificultades para
acercarse y
y negociar con este gobierno también
veremos unas declaraciones mucho más
radicales con seguridades
especialmente respecto a estados unidos
y gran bretaña es lo que podemos esperar
en cuanto a irak esperar es usted se
espera mayor acercamiento obviamente
irán tiene muchísimos intereses en
muchos países de la región y la la
respuesta estará también del lado iraquí
de otros países vecinos como responden a
estas políticas más radicales de la
nueva presidencia